comment va le monde sait ce dont nous
allons parler maintenant avec notre
invité qui sort un effet c'est amin
malouf
bonsoir vous sortez le dérèglement du
monde chez grasset on est en plein dans
l'actualité il a avec vous encore un
tout simplement
et ce livre commence par la chute du mur
de berlin il ya 20 ans et tout govou dit
l'europe n'a déjà pas été à la hauteur
de l'événement déjà à partir de ce
moment-là de l'événement de ce monde qui
se dérégler je pense effectivement que
la crise actuelle est le symptôme d'un
dérèglement plus basse on peut toujours
trouver des origines lointaines à ceux
des règlements mais pour moi la date de
référence et la chute du mur de berlin
il ya 20 ans je pense que c'était un
événement majeur très prometteur et
qu'on en a pas tirer les bonnes
conclusions notamment celles europe
notamment pour notamment en europe
les dix dernières années déjà le
leadership mondial
le leadership moral dans le monde avait
été abandonné par les états unis
pratiquement et l'europe aurait dû
occuper cette place elle ne l'a pas fait
alors du coup ça allait cesser ce que
vous dites de retrait c'est la place les
idéologies ont laissé la place à des
combats identitaire et particulièrement
dans des pays dont on parle
régulièrement dans l'actualité
l'irak l'afghanistan le pakistan et
c'est tout ça qui a pris la suite à la
suite de la chute du mur de berlin terre
moi je ne suis pas un nostalgique de
l'époque d'avant la chute du mur de
berlin mais il ya un point qui est
important il y avait un débat le monde
était divisé entre des des blocs mais
également des idéologies on débattait du
meilleur système politique économique
depuis une vingtaine d'années on ne
débat plus vraiment les gens affirment
leur identité les gens s'accrochent aux
identités le plus viscéral et il ya plus
de véritable débat et avec un problème
que vous développez aussi dans votre
essai c'est un problème de leadership de
légitimité qui peut donner un sens au
monde alors justement à ce propos est ce
que barack obama par exemple en appelant
l'iran au dialogue ou en desserrant
l'étau en irak
peut-être cette puissance ou ce pouvoir
légitime qui peut remettre le monde sur
pied pense que l'un des dérèglements qui
existe
une vingtaine d'années c'est au niveau
des relations internationales il ya un
pays les états unis qui joue un rôle
énorme dans le monde le président des
états unis est pratiquement le suzerain
dans le monde
est-ce qu'il a une légitimité strict à
strictement parler il n'en a pas il n'a
pas été élu par pat pas de la population
mondiale a été élu pas 5% de la
population mondiale est ce qu'il peut
avoir une certaine légitimité morale oui
s'il agit d'une manière conforme à
l'attenté de la population mondiale en
matière de de climat en matière de
droits de l'homme en matière de
démocratie et je pense que c'est c'est
sur son bilan que l'on pourra juger s'il
acquiert une légitimité
alors avant de faire le bilan il y à
tous les enjeux du moment dans ce livre
amin malouf le dérèglement du monde et
tout ce qu'on a vécu ces dernières
années et tout ce qui nous attend avec
les questions qui se posent merci
beaucoup d'énergie a eu l'idée évoquée
sur ce plateau ce soir et tout de suite
l'actualité des régions